is there a part of physics and astronomy
that really confuses you yeah lots of
lots of parts of physics and astronomy
really confuse me quite a lot of it
actually
certainly classical classic things like
quantum physics very few people have any
kind of intuitive understanding of it
and I certainly wouldn't count myself as
one of them Oh many areas I guess and
there are some areas where if you if it
doesn't confuse you that really just
tells you that you haven't understood it
so things like quantum mechanics and
relativity where the universe really
waves in a completely counterintuitive
way if you really think well that's
pretty obvious then I would say that
almost certainly means that you really
haven't understood it and it's only when
you're really confused by it that you're
really getting close to understanding it
yeah how did the universe begin I mean
what happened before the Big Bang we can
describe very detailed results of it and
make predictions but what initiated it
no idea no way to figure it out which
piece do you are we start I can cope
with a lot of the subject string theory
is way way beyond me the difficulty was
with with string theory is that I'm a
guess I'm an experimentalist ooh really
I do double in theory now and again but
what I want to see is a connection with
experiment I want to see connection with
with observations and with string theory
sometimes it's very difficult for me to
see what I thought that connection is I
can appreciate to some extent the
elegance of the mathematics and I can
appreciate why string theorists get so
excited they go we'll look at the beauty
of this look at it has to be right but
just because it's beautiful and just
because it's elegant mathematics doesn't
necessarily make it right some string
theory and it's not frustrating that I
can't figure out how to answer it it's
frustrating that I don't even know how
we can get any information from there
how do we go about answering that
question of no idea and that's really
frustrating I find I find the idea of
quantum computation very difficult the I
mean the basic principles I suppose are
not so hard if you're a professional
scientist but how you're going to to set
up the qubits and then nip
laid them and then read out the
information on any useful scale and
there's a lot of optimism about it I
guess maybe because I'm old I'm very
skeptical about the little thing but how
you can actually make a useful machine
out of it but maybe I'd be proved wrong
in 20 years I find general relativity
and I spent one summer writing notes of
myself on general relativity so at least
I had some understanding but it needs
beyond me
there usually to do with interfaces
where are you you think you have a
little bit of knowledge on one and a
little bit of knowledge on the other and
youth so you should be able to join the
two together and they don't quite work
so for example in in the field that I
work in I sometimes overlap with
cosmologists who think about galaxy
formation and the so the onset of what's
gone called going from the linear to the
nonlinear regime where you can do
everything nicely on pen and paper work
everything under linear and then you
know it's not going to it can't keep
doing that gravity takes over and it
becomes nonlinear and that interface I
find quite difficult to because I should
be able to do it that I can't quite get
it sorted out thermodynamics I always
struggled with a bit University yeah
that was that was not one of my best
courses there are lots of things which
are really quite technical which I I can
cope with but when it gets the general
relativity it goes off into another area